your brain can survive for several
minutes after your heart stops
but
what if
your brain took a time out and stopped
working
for five seconds
would you instantly be brain dead
what would happen to your other organs
and could your normal life functions
resume when your brain begins working
again
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if your brain stopped working for
five seconds
in case you haven't noticed your brain
is important
it controls your thoughts and movements
as well as all the bodily functions that
keep you alive
this amazing organ can survive up to six
minutes after your heart stops but
sometimes the human brain can take a
coffee break
when most of the brain activity shuts
down you could be in a coma or a
vegetative state
these conditions could be temporary or
permanent
but they are different from your brain
stopping completely
if your brain stopped for five seconds
all your primary functions like pulse
breathing and blood pressure would shut
down
but what would happen if your brain
started working again
could you go back to your everyday life
sorry to break it to you but if your
brain shut off for five seconds
you'd be brain dead and
brain death is irreversible
though at that moment you might not look
dead you'd seem to be in a deep deep
sleep
so before declaring you brain dead your
doctors would need to perform several
tests
they shine a light in your eyes to
confirm that your pupils are no longer
reacting
they'd also check whether you have any
reaction to pain or if your gag reflex
still kicks in
once it's confirmed you have no pulse
and no registered brain activity
you would be clinically dead
and sadly nothing can be done to reverse
this
your brain wouldn't be able to come back
to life five seconds later
but what would be happening to your body
well without any medical intervention
brain death would lead to multiple organ
failure hypothermia and respiratory
failure
since your lungs no longer work
your body wouldn't get any new oxygen
your cardiac muscles would start to die
within an hour or so your heart would
stop but the death process wouldn't end
there
about one week after your brain death
your kidneys would start to fail and so
would your immune functions
that's because your brain would no
longer be creating the hormones needed
for all the biological processes in your
body
you know if there's one bright side to
all of this it's at least you wouldn't
suffer
no you wouldn't feel anything
but that's only because you're
completely dead
if you're a registered organ donor the
doctors would have methods to keep your
body functioning for a long time even
after brain death they would need to
maintain a healthy environment for your
organs so they'd provide your body with
necessary medications hormones and
fluids
and they'd keep you on a ventilator
this breathing machine would inflate
your lungs with air to keep your heart
beating
as long as there's oxygen your heart can
keep on pumping
during this time they'd cover your body
in blankets to keep you warm
you would look like you were asleep
once the doctors harvested all the
organs they could
this treatment would cease
it would make no ethical sense to keep
your body alive
but it would all be worth it because
your organs would be available for
patients desperately waiting for organ
or tissue donations
and most organs come from brain dead
donors
but brain death doesn't happen all that
often
it occurs in only one out of every 200
hospital deaths
so you can see why organ transplants are
so hard to come by
or i guess you could see if you weren't
you know brain dead
now would it be any better if you were
in a coma and never woke up
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]